Hello Everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Case Animitronics.
Now apparently, we have the uh.. key card in our inventory.
But I don't know where
*Markimoo looking around*
Oh!
(Markiplier's mating call)
Ay Buddy, How's it going
So, I don't know where it goes.
Now there's a key card thin- *Spoopy Noise*
(Markiplier makes a wierd noise)
Fuck I did a bad.
Oh boy, Oh boy
Oh boy
It lost me
Okay so good thing it's really really not smart and full of dumb.
Otherwise I would have been dead there.....
K so obviously, I can't go through here.
*beeping noises* Or else it will beep and it'll come after me.
So I can't leave. *Markiplier still setting off noises* Even though I probably
have the authorization to do so.
Game logic (Staticy Noise)
What was that? Geez.
But game logic..
Game logic dictates
Door is locked with a keycard, But I have a keycard!
Oh that's not what I wanted.
So
Can I Swipey-Swoo?
I don't know how to sw-. What?
Okay.
Nope. Okay so that's not gonna work.
So there's gotta be another door with a key card somewhere around here.
and I'm gonna find it. I'll be back.
*Spoopy beep* There we go, got it. Okay, this is the one.
Who's in here.
Why are we in here.
Why are we in here? Is there more story untold?
Unfold, Untold whatever the word is I don't really care
What the hell happened? Oh no, No hide!
No time for hide!
It's just gonna kill me anyway
We gotta go, we gotta go
Oh it's coming.... Oh it's coming
Yeeeee
Where do I go?
Whedrdrdrlleto
No! Of course it's closed!
What do you mean safe is locked...
K
God dammit I need another key card.
Shit.
It's gotta be something here
There's gotta be something. Anything!
Why did I go in this rom!
What's that over there?
Ooo! Wait
Didn't I need this? (Mark happy face)
(Mark sees dark rooms with horrors)
Oh good! We have a frieeeeeeeend active.
Oh, hey.
Ohhhhhhhhh..
Ingame Character: Sick bastard. A giant cat. What else can you think of?
I should avoid the ventilation tubes
Yeah I prob- Heyyyy Fuck ah Fuck
*Markimoo defensive screech*
Ah!
Ah god! Don't kill me! (Headphone users get ready)
*Scream of ear destroying*
Ah, fuck off.
God dammit. How was I supposed to know it was gonna pop down right in the same room that I was.
What a load of asssssss
So I gotta find Ben's room
Now I've got
Where was Ben's room?
Ben's room in here?
Noh I think Ben's room was in the other part of the office...
Wasn't it?
Over here somewhere?
Euugh
Where do I look up?
In here?
Charger? No?
I feel like I would have known about this.
Man this, This tablet did not last long enough.
Okay so I gotta find without dying..
Not in here..
*Loud Thud*
Ah!
When and Why and How!
Eh!
Okay.
This isn't Ben's room at all!
This isn't Ben's room at ol!
How do we get to Ben's room..
Oh hello.
More story!
Can I read?
Our group leader has given us a task.
"Everybody must draw an unusual object or character for Halloween"
She said that she want our group to participate in an exhibit like no other.
I immediately recalled those animintronics from the pizzeria and drew!
Okay where are ya...
*Spoopy noise*
That's a good sound. But where are ya?
(Clanking footsteps get louder)
I've got a lot to-.
WAHHH! *Markimoo no like*
Oh Fucking Caaack!
(Markiplier get's sammiched)
Ahhhh! (Loud screaming) Fuck off!
Well I got aten!
*Thud* Ah shit.
Well that ain't good.
*Spoopy noise*
K just gonna go for it
Gonna gun for it
Gonna gun for it?
Shit.
The pick locks?!
Huh.
That's awfully a convenient explanation
I'm just gonna go for it.
Eugh! Is it in here?
Oh.. is it in here somewhere
Shit.
Okay gotta hide.
Ee gotta hide.
Hide. Lemme hide under! Eugh...
Oh no i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead.
Where is he? Where is he. God dammit.
He must be down that way. So I gotta stay in here and I gotta wait until he goes by.
*Markimoo sexy face*
Light off.
(That face when you are making a risky decision)
Wtf are you doin mark o.O
Ah sorry I got something in my throat.
*Munching sounds*
Agh! Just gotta make a lot of mouth sounds. ;3
(This is why markiplier doesn't have a girlfriend.)
I think they went away.
(No offense mark)
I. I pretty sure about it.
Now that I think about it, i'm pretty sure they are gone.
*Foot steps getting louder*
(Good job mark, good job!)
Ah!
It was not gone!
What the FAK!
It sounded like it was gaaaane!
Ah! (No wonder he died so much in fnaf 4, he can't dun here audio cues ;-;)
Come on come on
Go go go Run faster close door!
Augh!
Hide under the desk!
(Too late *Evil face*) AUgh!
BLERRGGHHHH!!!! Fuck off
*Sigh*
Sucks dick.
Stop. Don't do that.
I'm on edge!
This is the evidence storage room, is it not?
What is dis!
In the state of Colorado in the city of Aurora (Subnautica?), according to witnesses at 1:00 am, an unidentified gunman entered the house and threatened the family.
Neighbors and passers-by called the police reporting "A lot of noise" from the house.
A police officer arrived at the scene to what turned out to be his first call
During the struggle, a woman died and a man was wounded.
The owner of the house is currently hospitalized in a coma.
The criminal managed to escape, and even though the police officer did not sustain any injuries, he did undergo pyschological evaluation
The police refused to comment on the case
So what does that have to do with this?
I can only assume that it's all related somehow, I just have to find out how.
That might have been my first case
Maybe I botched it up and that's why this guy is mad at me.
He was robbed by someone I responded the scene, and someone got injured
His wife got killed.
Is that what happened?
Shit.
Okay yeah, go that way
Dick.
Stupid
Stupad Dick!
(Markiplier stalking the thing)
Shit.
Don't turn around.
Don't turn around..
Don't go in there!
I need to go in there...
Oh shit
He's not going in there
Eugh.. no
Nope! Shit
What do I do?
Is it going in there?
Yeah he's going in there
Okay..
Give me!
*Thud*
Oh!
That's bad
That's bad.
K
So we..
Oh shit.
God dammit!
(Animitronic teleports through wall to kill mark)
(Mark noticed audio cue) AH!
AH FUCK! God dammit I didn't know it was after me...
FucK!
God this is hard!
Now that there is 2 of them, it is insanely difficult to get around from A to B
It's going through the vents..
(Markimoo no liek noises)
WAT is DAT
(Here we have the nopebeeps from the Fuckthatanimintronic)
Wat is that!
(mark you should probably hide in another area...)
(This closet seems to...kill you)
Was that a cat
purring?
Geezums.
Okay.
Oh shit
Oh FAKIN CAAACKKK
GAD DAMMIT
FAAK
Oh god dammit i'm fuck i'm fuck i'm fuck i'm fucked
I'm fucked, I'm fucked, I'm fucked
Oh I'm fucked.
Am I fucked?
Am I not fucked?!
Ooo
Somehow...
Am no fuck!
I..
I don't know how...
*Thud* Euuugh fuck off
Okay, so in here? There we go
Okay!
So hopefully that's sauuuuuaved it
So hopefully.
I thought I was...
dead.
But now, am alive
Oh how did I close this door.
Woah. Uh oh
Cutscene!
Uh oh!
Ohhh naoo! Can I?
I can't do anything.
I can't see that
What do yu mean.
What do you mean it's just great
Went around!
He went the wrong way!
(PREPARE YOUR EARS!)
(It was at this moment Mark knew. He fucked up.)
AHHH! Oh FUCK me!
God!
Dammit!
Good thing it saved.
I saw the save icon, it better give me that god dammed checkpoint.
Okay so that's good.
Uagghh!!! Come on!
(Mark are you really gonna do the same thing again.)
How and why and How and wh-...
BLERRGGHHH!!! Again?!
I thought it was random chance it was there last time!
Wow I am dying alot, I apologize
*Thud* Augh Fucking Cock.
Go in there, go in there,  Get in there!
In in in, okay
They don't know I am here.
How would they?
It's a secret!
No one knows!
Right?
Man i'm sorry. I've made NO progress yet
Okay
So I just gotta wait for them to get out of here
and then i'll free and clear.
But for some reason,
They are...
Adament. about being all up in my butt.
They're like walking in tandum!
(And so the animatronic love story begins.)
Thankfully farther away though....
Okay, so this should be good.
Should be clear.
Alright we got this.
It's like...
What the hell?
There we go
Got it!
I'm in.
I'm in, close the door
Shut the blinds.
Okay, we are good.
So in here there should be..
No! Get. mmmm.
Let's see yeah, or duck straight underneath
What!
Ta-Dah!
Oh.
Sure.
That's how that works.
That's how technology works everybody!
Apparently...
Alright so.
So it's charging.. but it's not done yet
What's in here?
Why are there like locks on this?
Oh hello!
Well that looks important
Shume door, huh.
Well.
I bet I know what door it is...
I don't know if I.. Oh hey.
How's it going friend?
You coming straight for me?
All the way from you to me?
Let me get under here
First time I have actually used this
(Markimoo happy)
(Markimoo not happy) That didn't sound good
Okay.
Everything's gonna be A okay!
So long as he get's the fuck outta here.
and then I can go unlock the other...
key card
But I think, I think because this was was red
I think I remember seeing a red...
ah...
Somethin or other
Over beyond the door I already opened with the key card...
I think it's the door beyond that.
Which opens again.
Okay. I dont know which way he went.
Hopefully out. But yeah i think so out
I think definitely out.
Okay
So through
Oh
Eugh!
Vents!
I dun know!
LONNGGG ASSS SILLLEEENCEEEEEEEEEE (except for character diolauge)
(Markiplier realizes what is gonna happen) Oh no Oh no Oh no
No no no no no no NUAO
Don't do that. Eugh!
Don't purr at me!
Don't be purring
I don't like that.
(Cellphone: trolololololololol)
Wasn't me!
Shoo!
Shoo! Get on outta here
Get scared of a phone!
Get outta here!!
Okay.
I didn't see what was happening. I guess the flashlight doesn't really bother him
I don't imagine it does anyway
I'll answer that phone!
Yes I will.
Let me read this first.
In 1977 there was only one company that used animatronics for the amusement of children, while other companies used them for movies, which is very cool. I remember when i went to the restaurant. Shhghh They looked so real, what if they could walk!
yeah sure,
The fever dream of a child.
Dat me!
Dat live boy.
Dang.
Okay.
Sun of a bitch!
The ventilation system is off?
oh.
And my flashlight is dead.
It's perma-dead.
Okay, so that means i am on my own.
Surviving alone.
But i'm not gonna do it now!
I'm gonna do that in the next episode.
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
Sorry about all the death...
I'm very bad apparently.
But I'll get good later.
So thanks again
*in sexy voice* and as always, I will see you.
(IN YOUR NIGHTMARES. MWAHHAHAHAHAHAHAHA jk)
In the next video.
Buh bye! *End*